bello a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ad oggi siamo tornati
sua pièce col cappello da da pikachu
quanto vi è mancato il suo cappello dite
la verità centrale di ragazzi su happy
meals facciamo molto epic
proviamoci non so quanto possa essere
utile che cazz e quella roba lì
[Musica]
posso chiedervi una cosa ragazzi che
cazzo sta facendo ed in questo momento
[Musica]
va bene lasciamo perdere andiamo avanti
nel world tour ed basta co sti v di un
render quanti ce ne sono preferiresti
mangia ancora questa lampada la frutta
mangiare frutta per sempre o fast food
per sempre la frutta perché sono una
persona salutare io preferiresti essere
un aquila o essere un'ostrica [ __ ]
perché dovrei essere un'ostrica spiega
preferiresti avere un cane tipo doge che
sarebbe questo
questo è il cane doge videogames
illimitati
beh il caleno di portare a cagare mentre
i videogames no infatti tutti i
videogame prevedersi insegnare scienze
insegnare storia scienza tutta la vita
santo di dio festi morire primo a morire
ultimo checa si domanda ma se le scene
ma che charlie ovvio è il 90 per cento
alla questa risposta grazie a cazzo
prevedesse essere immortale ma povero
ricco ma mortale immortale ma povero 10
mila volte
porca [ __ ] non riesca cliccarlo
grazie al cazzo che immortale ma povero
perché va ai ricchi si compra una bella
tomba e io ci piscio sopra 55 ma
[ __ ] chi è che ha messo 50 ricco e
mortale teste di minchia
vabbè andiamo avanti ragazze halloween
ambulan addirittura hanno fatto un
arpione ratio ma che si cerca un run in
inglese corsa arpioni
sì
e per chi è cieco e stupido tipo ma non
avevo miste mai le ha pure scritto mine
sono soprattutto poi col cazzo altamente
ok perfetto ai ripari poi chi gia e che
vittoria ragazzi lanci the bay di
minchia come lei lanciato bene ma devo
metterlo sul vassoio caffè perfetto hai
centrato in pieno zio siete andati 11 di
provo ma quanto sei rincoglionita ma
veramente niente nero che hanno devo
premere un tasto sbagliato il pretesto
no deve finire in teoria renon ma non ce
la farà mai ragazzi impossibile
si no troppo
no no
no
cazzo fa chiesto ce l'ho fatta tirati
suo figlio suo testo sud a [ __ ]
vabbè non fa niente sono contento tua
madre fiera uguale became a bottle flip
diventa un botto il flip papa come ma
cosa ma cosa ma cos'è la nava non ci
credo qui quindi devo chiederti come
cazzo fatto uscire spiegano no devo
cadere in piedi fermi ci devo provare
devo cadere in piedi zio i piedi in
piedi in piedi frate in piedi esatto va
bene samparisi gower a vetan rame
non cade non cade tua sorella putrefatta
perfetto no devi kart frate ok niente il
tipo non cade ragazzi è impossibile ma
come faccio oggetto come cosa sono fatta
sono sopra una macchina che non so con
quale motore si stia muovendo ma va bene
lo è più visto è sempre più strano lega
non ha senso ragazzi per il prossimo
livello bisogno di un tantino di colonna
sonora abbiate pazienza né ragazzo o le
porte a una nave sta bene non è stata
vera di una certa vena affanculo
insomma smartclip bellissimo società ma
vecchia ieva ball ai eva poco a lo
mancata ai e bubble ai eva cazzo di poco
ha fatto gol
poco o con il togo fatto il gol con il
volgo fatto il gol a basta è finita
ah già è vero che durava un calcio bello
ma le farfalle father mother me ha fatto
già finita io sono meno perché so di
roma si vedono una donna io li sacco
perizoma che c'è da fare e va beh sì
gran cazzi www.io samir io no dormir da
una settimana controllare se il modello
è l'altra pro fermi ho bisogno di
concentrazione ragazzi basta samir
cos'era cos'è giusto giusto giusto si
cazzo questo volevo grandissimo luca
saracino ischemiche siete forse mi
mancava un botto regalo perfetto no no
no vabbè che non era questo di skate
dell'ocs che volevo fare io porca
[ __ ]
questo lo odio ma che cazzo di problemi
child sono sono sono un [ __ ] sono un
[ __ ] tahiti poi ancora spingere
fatti poi ancora spingere frate dai
frate dai fratelli di zio la tua sorella
putrefatta ignobile maghetto ok una vita
per fa sta roba una vita chille york
boss provavano con nonno ciak dati
sembrano michia quanto quanto isterico
nonno ti ammazzo la madre ti ammazzo la
famiglia caduta perché c'è un tuo
braccio nel mio culo ci provo il caduto
pure ralenti cioè fantastico
[Musica]
esiste
nei nomi mitch siedo anche sopra secondo
me è quasi impossibile 99,99 per cento
quanti 99 ok il casino che cazzo state
calmi che problemi non esalta militi non
esattamente quello che non è esattamente
quello che volevo fare però c'è un mio
braccio che vola sono fiero di fate
capire come faccia a vincere con tutti
stì arpioni imposti cesena ragazzi hanno
messi troppi qua impossibile veramente
non posso mai vincere cioè assurdo
seppure le mine no raga questa
infattibile è un attimo il secondo no
dai ho vinto non ero morto testa di cura
non ero morto
ma perché non può escludere mina mina in
faccia con loro non ho neanche toccato
il cuore arrivi il quadrato questo che
stavo dicendo quadro ardono giocatore la
fiorentina non mancano toccato il
traguardo ma stavo vincendo va bene così
l'xc un giorno bene allora terminati ma
terminato in fa min attimo mi si è
riusciti andava una donna che strage
incredibile giorno senza zio e avrei
bisogno
perfetto dovrei in teoria passare non me
ne frega un cazzo se c'è uno che si sta
suicidando li gentilissimo ti togli
dalle chine grazie grazie
cos'è niente limoni in mezzo alla folla
cast c'è perché c'è la liuc che pulp al
faber nation pelle con l'assist a droga
un bellissimo sto gioco sta diventando
sempre più istruttivo ho collezionato un
sacco di cuori nella mia vita io ma
letteralmente c'è proprio quella di
insomma proprio un
rubacuori ma proprio di serie di foto li
vendo al mercato nero pervertito what
are you doing e che ne sono parte 2
no no grazie non l'affare la x 2 va bene
così the nine macchie del 79 per cento
va bene the deadly line up incazzata di
mia madre con la volta che ho portato un
2 a casa tirano
lui decide di vincere va bene così non
importa ok è un problema suo ma ha
deciso che ho vinto e va a messa bene
basta molto bene the final vostro
livello finale ragazzi a ma anche the
final quindi facciamo questo come
livello finale che mi sa di figo pezzoli
del file perché finale che non ci
saranno più l'ultima volta l'ho della
vita o milito chiese ho vinto un cazzo
andiamo su victoria se riuscisse perché
lo dice la serve fantastico grazie mi
serve proprio un'anguria in questo
momento porca [ __ ] come come faccio a
perdere così
il potere dell'ascella valere che suoli
basta è stato quanto bello ma direi che
posso finire qua le mie doti da happy
uil si sta che sono dovrebbe essere uno
sport olimpionico il giocatore di happy
uil sia sarei il number one
purtroppo per me è questa la dice lunga
su quanto sia triste la mia vita e spero
che se invece dovesse servirvi un
momento è un mi piace anche a pagine di
facebook come nido a trattare
descrizione sensi gli schiavi ci
mettiamo così bello ragazzi